let me ask
a little bit out there question maybe
it's a speculation but
maybe touching on roswell
do you think it's possible that there is
out of this world aircraft
or beings that are
in the possession of one of the
governments on this earth
like the us government is it possible so
the one perspective of that
if it's possible is it possible to keep
a secret like that
i would say this i think it's very it's
highly possible
because if you go if you just look at
all the sightings and let's go
just look at project blue book oh it was
what the forget how many thousands of
sightings
and there's a percentage it's like 10 or
15 percent they still can't explain
like our tic tac is one of them you know
they basically the government has come
out and said we don't know what that was
okay so so if you go okay of that 15
that we don't know and of these
thousands they're still that 15
makes up a pretty big number what are
the chances that not one of them crashed
somewhere on the globe
and was recovered and i don't care if
it's a in-tax system
or you've got pieces of it of a metal
that we can't explain
or some some um biological
matter to say the least it could be
intact or it couldn't but
the the odds of that now are starting to
go down that
you know that could never happen and i'm
not talking just the united states i'm
talking the world
globally so is there a chance that a
foreign government actually possesses or
our government
or someone in the in the world on the
globe of the seven plus billion people
has something that is not from this
world and i'm not talking to meteor but
something that was
manufactured in some way that allowed
transport
or observation it could be a drone could
be a foreign drone you know like voyager
flies around and does all that stuff and
we got stuff that just went past pluto
that's out in the kuiper belt
you know there's there's stuff out there
floating around and what about ours it's
going to crash into jupiter eventually
or whatever
because we've had stuff crashing the
planets so if that's the case
you would think something is out there
that we have something that we can't
explain and according to
lou there's stuff that we can't explain
you know and i would assume that lou who
ran atip
has has seen stuff that he can't openly
talk about
because you know because i had a
clearance when you have a clearance
you are you sign your name you're bound
to that and to me that's an important
oath
that you hold to you know this is kind
of where uh
you know people have issues with bob so
if
you know and i leave it to you to
determine if you believe bob or not i'll
tell you bob is a straightforward
very sane normal super smart guy
yes there is the other side that says
well should he have come out and talked
you know to those who will clearance who
you know are true
to the government you would say he
should have never spoke he
he was under an oath to not say anything
but he did
if you asked bob why did you say
something his the his
answer was i understand there's an oath
but i felt that the technology
could benefit all of mankind and it
shouldn't be locked away
and i'll leave if you believe bob that's
that's kind of what bob says
and that this is such a interesting key
point
if there is aircraft a technology that's
in the possession of the
say the us government should they make
that publicly known
this is this note in question this is
the question of like
do we release stuff that can potentially
change
the nature of human civilization like
the
the way we the way we think about our
place in the world
also the if that technology is
potentially
useful for military applications
the nature of military conflict should
we release that information or not
if you were the government so here well
here's exactly how so
for for classified information the
government is the people that classify
it
so i can't go i can't look at something
and go oh my god
this avion bottle is now top secret i
can't i don't have the authority the
ability or anyone to do that
that's up to the government and i agree
with that because i worked for the
government for 24 years of my life so
i understand that but now you go
there's reason stuff is classified okay
and it has to do with sometimes
information is classified by how it was
obtained
it's just like the mob if i have a spy
i'm a mobster and you're the counter
mobster but i have a guy on the inside
that's feeding me information
i can't do it and a perfect example is
if you've ever seen the uh
it's the tom cruise movie what is it air
america or whatever but he
he plays the guy in louisiana who was
hauling drugs for pablo escobar
and he ended up getting a cargo plane
and the government the cia was kind of
funding him to do stuff
that's how he got hooked up with pablo
but they put cameras on his airplane and
when reagan had come out and said here's
pictures we have proof that they're
running these drugs
it didn't take pablo long to figure out
those pictures were taken from inside of
the plane of this guy he had been
working with and that guy ends up dead
does that make sense so you classify to
protect the source
you classify to protect the technology
because if the technology would get out
it could be
grave damage or there's levels depending
on if it's a secret or top secret
there are levels of damage that can be
done to the us government and our
well-being as a country
and we owe it to this because we're all
americans you know to me
no matter what some people will say even
in this country this is the greatest
country on the planet
this is the only country that you have
the ability to do what you want to do
it's just don't be lazy and i have
stories of people that came over here
and started with nothing
and they're they're living the american
dream and they'll tell you
and they didn't get it because of you
know like you you came over here
from russia you get no minority status
or anything else you get
you're a white anglo-saxon protestant
whatever
you're religious but you come over here
i kind of knew that from the last time
but
um but you come over here you basically
have made yourself
you're educated you're working at
literally the top
research university in the world to be
honest
um i can do whatever the hell i can
create and
with a bit of with a lot of hard work i
can do quite
and no one gave it to you yeah so i mean
and i well
i'm a believer that like i mean
we are a community so like
there is a social aspect to it but the
freedom
and the american dream is a real thing
and this is this i
you know i joke about being russian but
i i'm an american
and this is i do believe the greatest
country on earth so
there's a reason the nationalist pride
uh the pride in your nation is a
powerful thing and
around that this secrecy
holds value but to me alien technology
is bigger than that i mean it's it's not
so much a threat as a you're holding
back
something that could inspire the world
like
human knowledge so let's talk in theory
so
i'm gonna go back to bob because i've
talked about
so bob is a propulsion guy
right right bob has a bicycle with a
rocket motor he built a rocket car
you know so he did that so if you are
trying to figure out a propulsion system
let's just say this is i'm just talking
this is dave's theory
i am i own i have i have custody of this
thing from a technology that i don't
understand
and i know it's a propulsion system so
now i got to figure it out
right so who are you gonna go to right
you go find someone so you go wait
here's a guy
who at the time was working at los
alamos which they have proven
who is big into propulsion he designs
all this he builds a [ __ ] in his garage
hey he's super smart why don't we bring
him in
so you hire him on a contract and you go
hey we're going to brief you into a
program and he goes and works on
wherever he says he worked you know
that's not important but you get access
to the technology to try and figure it
out
and then you go well you know bob comes
out and says you know i
we're figuring out these things but
there's a part where our technology
isn't advanced enough for us to figure
the whole thing out
so then you know and let's just say bob
doesn't come out and tell anyone
he he works on it until he gets to the
point where he's stagnated
he he he said he's in a wall you go i
can't do it so sometimes the best thing
is to bring in a fresh mind so you go
find someone else who's in a propulsion
you bring him and they work
they can't figure it out or they get to
the point where kind of back to the
einstein theory where hey i've got all
these theories on how it works but we
don't have the technology we haven't
advanced enough to actually do what we
need to do we still have to advance
technology more
so then what do you do you shelve it you
go hey good project's over end the
contract you shelf it
and you wait another 10 years and you
wait another 10 years until
technology and our abilities and our our
research advances more
and then you go find new people to bring
in that are experts in that field and go
hey we want you to work on this thing
and here's what we know about it so far
or you don't tell them anything because
because remember if you
if you reveal someone else's research
you can taint their beliefs they'll
start to sway in that direction so you
go
i'm not going to tell you anything i'm
going to give you this thing and now you
tell me what you think and as they
progress if they get stuck
on a problem that maybe bob and someone
else solved earlier you can go hey what
about this you don't have to tell where
it came from
what about this and now they can
leapfrog and they get another two steps
closer to the final answer
and then we get stuck by our evolution
of technology do you shelve it again do
you think that's the right way to
do it because it's heartbreaking i don't
listen i love government but we just had
this discussion about
elon and so on the the alternative
approach
is to release this to the
world and say there's a mystery here and
then the elons of the world the jeff
bezos
who talked about money but it's also not
just money it's like
this engine that's within we talked
about the american dream
to say i'm going to be the one that
cracks this mystery open
and like that's within a lot of us and
like money aside
people in their garage just will but
you're thinking like a scientist now let
me
now let's shift to let me think like a
country so we have country a
b and c and you can look at the nuclear
arms race so we know that
germany was really close we know that
russia was getting pretty close
we just won the race and we were the
first ones with it yeah
and still to the state germany could
have won they could have won
they could have won but someone was
smart enough to not finish the equation
when they knew they had the answer
it's literally what it comes down to
someone was smart enough to realize if
that that got into
the hands of the nazis that it would be
the end
and and that's that's a tough call to do
that
knowing that you have the answer and you
can't solve the problem because it will
go into the wrong hand
and that's kind of the fear when you
look at this you go okay so if we do
this
if we put it out there we've got this
technology
if we don't work on it kind of
international space station like we're
all going to work on it together
in uh you know like antarctica is really
supposed to be
treaty free from any weapons or anything
we're supposed to we got the
international thing down there we're all
going to work together
if you did it in a in the confines of
that and you could control the flow in
and out
because what you don't want is the
someone stealing information and getting
it back to where
and countries are notorious to do this
hey we're doing internationally but
we're secretly doing it ourselves to see
who can come up with a solution first
that's the problem because we have this
inherent thing of
power and technology like that is power
it would literally change the game of
the way the world operates
and from not just the transportation or
mankind
but from a military aspect it's got huge
huge
uh yeah yeah i guess so beautifully
beautifully presented and there's i feel
like there's a tension between those two
plates the scientists view of the world
and the national security view of the
world
let me get to this kind of interesting
point which is
a lot of conspiracy theorists kind of
paint a picture of government as an
exceptionally as a hierarchical system
that's exceptionally competent
and good at hiding secrets and then
i mean i tend to not subscribe to almost
any conspiracy theory
to the degree at least that the
conspiracy theorists do uh
i agree with you but the
there does seem to be and i tend to
think of government as unfortunately
uh incompetent at least the bureaucracy
it seems that the communication like the
three videos that were released
and just the way of dod in general talks
about the things we've been talking
about it's just confused this
contradictory
it's not inspiring it's it's uh
suspicious it's just not even the way
they release the videos
you know the tic tac if presented
correctly
could just inspire a generation of
scientists it's like
you know us going to the moon and
it's inspiring i mean it's incredible
like you know and and the way it was
released was suspicious it was like
low resolution video on a crappy website
like with some crappy documents
and uh i mean why what i don't know how
to ask this question but
can government do better why are they
doing it this way in terms of
communicating the things they do know to
the public because i don't think they
know how
especially in this topic it's been
hidden for so many years
and i don't think uh because i don't buy
off on the conspiracy stuff
i just think that you know when it comes
in like i said you know the government
has a right to classify stuff
they they classify everything because
they don't know you have something you
don't know what it is you don't know so
we just go well it must be
must be top secret and let's put it in a
vault you know it's kind of like the
indiana jones where they take the ark
and they put it in they
it's in the giant army warehouse um you
know we don't even know what we have
so but i also believe that you know and
i'll say this openly i don't think that
the american people
need to know everything i think there's
a reason that stuff is classified for
the protection of this country uh and i
totally
believe in that so you know and i was
joking with joe when he was talking
about
storm area 51 stuff i'm like yeah that's
probably the worst idea you could
possibly have is to just storm a
military installation
it's just stupid there are reasons there
are reasons that we have things that we
don't just let out to the public
because if we do as soon as you do let
someone know that you have something
they immediately try and encounter it
and perfect example
the us and the 60s developed a bomber it
was a mach 3
compression lift bomber called the xb70
okay
there was three of them built three of
them ever built it was a
like 60 000 foot high you know mach 3
there's an incredible airplane when you
see it there's actually the last one
remaining is in dayton ohio at the
museum
you know it would go that wingtips would
fall down it looks like a concord but
it's way faster
when that got out that we were
developing it the soviet union developed
the mig-25
literally a high-altitude interceptor to
counter that bomber
and they built an entire fleet of
mig-25s
right we built three xb70s and we
scrapped the program
right because now you go well it's the
technology is cool we proved it but now
it becomes obsolete so it's not even
worth building a whole fleet of these
things
you know it's constant it's a chess game
we do something they do something we do
something they do something and it's
we do something and then they counter it
they gotta it's you gotta figure out how
to defeat it
so you go oh we'll build something so
the more we keep
uh quiet especially from a defense
standpoint
the better we actually at personally i
think we talk too much and i think the
the military and the dod is starting to
see that you know we're too open
you know you know you announce hey we're
building this because there's a budget
line and we live in a free society
um but you don't have to release all the
specs
and you don't have to put everything in
open source but that's a problem when we
go to
the universities if we want to go do
work with mit and you want to partner
with mit and you're a defense company
and you want to partner
you know you guys have a rule that if
you create it then it can be open source
because the university owns it and we
are
an institution of learning where the
defense side might go
we don't we don't really want that
published in a paper in scientific
america or i call it
i talked to the cto of lockheed uh koko
jackson and just
just conquers the some of the best if
not the best
engineering and science but engineering
really
ever is done in secrecy
and it sucks because it's so inspiring
and they can't talk about it
it is due to funding the us government
has deep pockets
you know some of this new technology
that you develop for an open source
unless
this goes back to the original
conversation we now there's enough money
in the private sector that
individuals control bayes i'm not
talking
amazon i'm talking jeff bezos a single
individual worth over 100 billion
dollars he has the ability to do stuff
i'll tell you what
the gates foundation with between bill
gates and and
and his his wife and warren buffett and
some of the other money because i think
bezos's ex-wife actually donated a huge
chunk of her half into the
gates foundation so i mean what's the
gates foundation worth these days
you know if and these are guys you know
brilliant
brilliant i mean some of the greatest
minds we have to go you know what are
they doing because they have the ability
it's a non-profit they can go hey i want
to fund this i want to fund this
research
they can look beyond the conflict
between nations you can look beyond the
conflict of having to have
you know classification you can do what
you want you know
it's just like you know we classify how
to do
uh you know the whole nuclear you know
how to create a critical mass
right but there's really smart high
school kids that have figured out
mathematically and they do their science
project and then the government comes in
and says hey we got to classify your
government because we just don't want
this out in the public domain
which i understand but they never stop
them from free thought and developing
that it's just
we really don't want this out there okay
so i understand that
i totally understand that but if they
you know if if bill and melinda want to
do this and go hey we want to do this
and they're going to work with bezos and
they're going to work with elon and
we're going to
be think about it there's a significant
amount of money that could be available
to r d and i'm not talking just science
like this i'm talking
medical research and all this but then
you go who gets it because now you're
competing against
the companies that actually do it you go
is that well are they the
greatest minds i'd say you know the
we have a tendency to go these are the
best that we have and i'd say well no
that's the best that we know we have
but there's probably people out there
that don't want to work there's
brilliant minds that don't want to do
anything with defense because they just
disagree with what it does
so they go to another path they can do
something else
and that in a sense like the elons of
the world that jeff bezos
actually in a certain sense much better
than
dod at finding the brilliant weird minds
out there
because they're not tied to the
government so when you work a government
contract
the government writes they tell you what
they want and then they work with you on
the requirements and they usually have a
an end in mean you know they have an
idea that this is what i want it to be
where if you go to like spacex
where you know they come up with why
don't we just
land these things on a pad and reuse
them yeah well if the government
scientists if you're on a government
contract says no that's not the
requirements we're not paying for that
we want you to do this
you're kind of controlled or when elon
does it his company
they can do whatever the hell they want
to do because they have no bounds the
only bounds they have is the liability
if it doesn't work and it lands on
something so what do you do you go out
to kwajalein and you test it if it
crashes and it lands in the ocean hey we
clean it up no big deal we lost some
money
but we'll move on it's you know money
makes the world go around contrary to
what everyone thinks but
you know there's a lot of money that's
sitting around that you can do a lot of
really cool stuff with and i don't know
i mean i'll guarantee that uh what is it
blue origin
isn't that amazon yeah you know that
they're doing some cool stuff because
they have
funny and i joke with the guy i know
that worked at spacex and
he was funny because they were building
the first test thing
and they they were limited and elon
found this like 400 acre
thing i think it's about 400 acres down
by waco texas
and he's like i go how he goes he goes
dude i worked he goes i worked with
he goes because he's done government
contract he goes there's government
contract and then there's
working at spacex with elon money and
that's what he refers to it as his elon
money where it was like
don't i'll throw them and he would throw
the money at it and make it happen and
it's i'm talking this fast
yeah i mean he talks about he has a
great story about this i mean this is
elon
this is how fast you can do in the
private sector vice the government where
there's the bureaucracy is
they had a company that was a basically
a tool and die machine shop that did a
lot of their high precision
parts for the rockets they had went to
the guy but he had contracts with other
companies and when the economy was down
the guy was actually looking at going
out of business so the guy i know
he's telling me the story he he was
talking to the guy he had to go over
there and get something and he's like
holy [ __ ] he goes hang on so he calls up
on the phone
spacex he says hey is elon there can you
get him in the board room we'll be there
in 20 minutes
so he grabs this guy who's literally
going to fold his company
they go over to spacex and i may be
getting some of this wrong if people are
going to fact check me but this is
pretty close
they go in the boardroom and and he said
literally
within like you know an hour or two
elon has bought the guy's company that
guy is now a senior vp
running the his company and they're
gonna pull all the stuff into the spacex
thing so they can actually build the
parts and they can still contract
out to make the money outside and it
happened like
that fast it's not just money it's
because i've seen i witnessed it too
with elon
i think it's uh whatever the whatever
the forces of capitalism that
that uh allow a person like elon musk to
rise to the top
but like because i've also worked for
darpa like for research for
in terms of a source of funding i i
there's a weight of bureaucracy
when i was working like being funded by
darpa
and with elon like i was literally in
the presence of like
anything is possible cutting across all
the [ __ ]
of paperwork of the way things were done
in the past
of the bureaucracy the rules the
constraints the
all of that stuff just you can cut
across immediately
how much money and time do you waste
dealing with your bureaucracy when you
could actually be doing real work
that's the difference this is why i
honestly when i went back to the
industrial defense complex that we were
warned
about when you look at it and go spacex
can do something for half the price
ahead of schedule
that what boeing were paying boeing and
you go oh
well this just came out and you go well
then why are we even dealing with this
side when we can deal with this side
yeah
because you've got a fully automated
capsule that has a manual mode that they
got to fly around in
it worked like a champ it went up it
hung out it came back
it splashed down it worked perfectly
you know we're going to dust it off and
oh by the way unlike the apollo capsules
that were used and then
put to museums they're going to reuse
that dragon capsule it came down they're
going to dust it off put a new coat of
paint on it slap it on top of another
rocket and away it goes
holy cow it's amazing it's a shift it's
a complete shift in mentality and for us
as taxpayers we can explore at half the
cost yeah
it's exciting especially given putting
the tic tac in context
like then the sky or
but it's limitless the possibilities we
could do with this kind of mechanism
i think it's exciting yeah i think we
live in an exciting time right now
besides everything that's
messed up in the world right now well
this is a this is a hopeful like there's
so much conflict going on so much
tension
uh that's to me space exploration at the
moment
it's a reason to uh get up in the
morning and
have a hope for the future to look up to
the sky and
we're humans we can like solve so many
we can solve all this i was talking
about when i was doing the tucker thing
and i said uh
this would be great you know because
when the government had come out you
know a month ago and said hey
this does exist we're doing this and
we're going to release more stuff
and i was texting like lou and chris
mellon and those guys
before i went on because they had called
me up to be on tucker's show and i'm
like hey i go
you know this would be great you know
just come out with this
find the the relic of a spaceship like
pull out the roswell wreckage if you
have it
pull out the roswell wreckage and do it
god it would be so nice to not have to
deal with
the the riots in the cities and i mean i
know it's an election year and all that
but
god it would be something it would be
refreshing to not have to turn on my tv
and see everything that is just
depressing in the world to begin holy
cow we actually do have this and we're
working on this technology
imagine if there is a roswell aircraft
and they pull it out
imagine the innovation that happens in
the next 10 to 20 years
without any more information than that
just the
the innovation that happens the look on
elon musk's face
look on jeff bezos's face and all the
brilliant engineers we changed the game
it would change it would change the game
completely
you